rappel en france au service national est
obligatoire pour tous les hommes et les
femmes peuvent être incorporés à leur
demande duré dix mois solde de militaire
4 195 francs par mois cette année deux
cent huit mille jeunes gens auront servi
sous les drapeaux
mais d'autres formes de service national
peuvent être proposés tout commence par
le centre de sélection passage obligé
avant l'incorporation reportage sur un
rite qui parfois marque la fin de
l'adolescence
7h30 un matin de la semaine comme tant
d'autres à limoges gare des bénédictins
les limites du cs 4 le centre de
sélection militaire du grand sud-ouest
observe les arrivées établissent le
premier contact avec ces jeunes souvent
intimidés qui viennent faire ce que l'on
appelle les trois jours tout est un
qu'il a un peu qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète
l'armée
et pas envie de faire l'armée
encadrés dès leur arrivée transporter
jusqu'à la caserne
ces garçons ont en fait passer
uniquement deux demi journées sur place
et rendez vous orchestré jusqu'à un
certain point pour opérer bien le trajet
quand ce soir vous rentrerez à pied tu
penses que c'est une journée importante
dans une vie ce jour là pour quelle
raison parce que j'ai envie de faire un
mini card carrière parce que c'est je
pense que ce sera mon avenir
chaque année le 16/04 de limoges décide
également de l'avenir de 35 mille jeunes
garçons soumis aux obligations
militaires
trente cinq mille citoyens qui pour des
raisons différentes se pose toujours la
même question en entrant ici
suis-je apte à effectuer le service
national
la réponse dépend exclusivement d'une
très longue série de tests médicaux et
psychotechniques
on est sans doute tombé l'armée toujours
l'armée mais toujours changerai pas
d'avis en biométrie stomatologie
urologie rencontres avec les médecins
généralistes et orl ophtalmologistes et
si nécessaire psychiatre le bilan est
complet certains comme ce jeune homme
peuvent avoir des difficultés à
effectuer ce parcours du combattant
les experts auront donc la
responsabilité de déterminer s'il s'agit
d'un véritable handicap ou bien de
comédie de simulation et si vous voulez
amorcé le sujet des simulateurs
je crois que même elle ça peuvent dire
qu'il y a au moins autant de gens qui
essaient de de simuler une aptitude que
de gens qui essaient de simuler une
inaptitude
depuis plusieurs années le nombre
d'individus considérés inapte pour
raisons médicales
donc exemptés avoisine les 20% il faut
savoir que les critères de sélection
varie en fonction des besoins de l'armée
le commandement peu joué en durcissant
ou adoucissant les normes ce qui veut
dire qu'un jeune qui aura les mêmes
symptômes les mêmes maladies peu une
année être exemptés et l'année suivante
en fonction des besoins mais est repris
pour effectuer le service militaire
aussi légèrement que cela mais
théoriquement oui c'est aussi est ce
qu'il n'ya pas là une injustice c'est le
commandement prend ses responsabilités
et s'appuie sur la loi pour obtenir les
ressources dont il a besoin pour sa
défense pour d'autres ministères
l'armée s'offre aussi le pouvoir de
déterminer le potentiel intellectuel de
ces futurs soldats trois séries de tests
puzzle meka et série cycliques
permettent ainsi de juger l'efficacité
au raisonnement l'intelligence pratique
et technique et la compréhension verbale
les possibilités d'affectation pourront
être liée aux résultats de ces tests des
exercices également précieux dans le
cadre des études sur l'illettrisme en
france selon le ministère de la défense
vingt pour cent des garçons qui passent
dans les centres de sélection
rencontrent des problèmes plus ou moins
graves de lecture et d'écriture
enfin au terme de cette journée
d'évaluation le couperet tombe
lors de l'entretien avec le fils
orienteurs une rencontre décisive
particulièrement en cas d'aptitude
puisqu'il est désormais possible
d'exprimer des souhaits quant aux lieux
d'affectation
quant à l'emploi et la date
d'incorporation
la journée je crois qu'elle la
discipline qui va encore cet acte ça
vous fait peur non j'étais volontaire
comment s'est passé ce premier contact
c'est des militaires faut pas leur en
vouloir
c'est qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez
c'est l'autorité quoi il aime ça je faut
pas leur alors enlever ça et là vous
êtes app shop
je vais faire dix mois avec eux c'est ça
vous fait peur non
avec du piston toujours ça on peut
arriver à tomber on veut quoi en matière
d'affectation tout se décide ici dans ce
bureau du service national à poitiers je
dirais que le mot pistons donc c'est
vrai qu'on en parle mais en réalité
c'est un faux problème
pourquoi parce que tout simplement nous
arrivons affecter les jeunes au plus
près de chez eux en fonction de leurs
qualifications et que le véritable
piston entre guillemets je dirais pour
nous en tant que pur de poitiers
n'existe pas le jeune aura une
affectation dans une unité correspondant
à ces qualifications
il ya quelques années on tenait un petit
peu moins compte des souhaits des jeunes
et l'alpiste on était plus important
peut-être hui 64
le mécanicien toujours drapeau williana
tous les deux mois quelques 3500
dossiers de jeunes du grand sud-ouest
près être incorporé sont gérés à l'aide
de ces immenses tableaux 80% des
affectations se font désormais dans la
région d'origine un travail manuel
humains sentimentale qui tente de mettre
en adéquation les souhaits des futurs
soldats et les besoins de l'armée
voilà c'est la fin de ce magazine merci
de nous être fidèles on se retrouve le
mois prochain pour un nouveau numéro de
re sud même sean même heure au revoir
à
ans